[Applause]
thank you very much oh well the accent
so you're not from here sadly not no
where are you from I'm from Wales
well yeah beautiful I played there have
um well not if yeah nice to you they
love going really UK Europe all I love
it good yeah so wait since you're from
Wales did you grow up watching mr.
Roeder no no very sadly and all the
poorer for it we sadly he never made it
across the Atlantic so we never got to
know mr. Rogers I have obviously in the
last few years and and as a result my my
three-year-old son has incredibly so but
no we were Buddha prizes yes it's a fun
age sometimes not
yes it's three n'ajjer true yeah so when
did you learn about mr. Rogers literally
when the school when the script landed
in my lap and and I turns to my other
hat my better half and I said who's mr.
Rogers and she went get out and she very
quickly explained that mr. Rogers I was
already familiar with mr. Rogers
unbeknown to me because our three year
old was watching Daniel Tiger's
neighborhood legacy you yes so then I
went on to watch the show on YouTube and
familiarize myself that way and sansamp
my three year old then became transfixed
isn't it funny as a parent you're kind
of like woo this is slow units for kids
it's like so important yes I quickly
realized in initially going what's
happening here why has he forgotten the
words why is it so slow yeah why is he
not well I'm not cutting trying to do
they only have one camera why they're
not cutting coming out and I didn't
realize that he had thought meticulously
about the pacing that the pacing
children need of a certain age so that
they have the chance to listen and to
process and to feel listened at this
time when he was being incredibly brave
when he said you know children's
entertain entertainment is becoming
about custard pies that you need to you
need to go the opposite direction slow
down for them yeah and he tackled
subjects that you're afraid to talk to
with your kids you know so breath in in
brain effort in every sense yeah but he
didn't see it as brave that's the cool
you know just sort of something you
should absolutely do
I'm so happy you're honoring him today I
think it's so important I grew up on him
so I love mr. Rogers but a big moment is
when mr. Rogers or mines Lloyd what's
your character in the movie and he
reminds you of your favorite childhood
toy old rabbit right yeah yeah yeah and
that's a really kind of pivotal moment
in the movie yes incredibly sad and I
don't know for those who do know don't
know it was it is the film is based on
this actual Esquire article that
happened yeah back in the 90s when when
mr. Rogers character was a real writer
for his boys he was and there's this
incredible article that Tom do you know
the journalist that Lloyd is based on
wrote this piece it's very moving how he
touches on that very same subject of I'm
something that Fred Rogers knew
intrinsically well how children relate
to these kind of talismans early in your
life yeah so did you have one did you
have a toy when you're a kid I did I did
I had a teddy bear that I was given the
day I was born that I very originally
named Ted always the og Ted the og no no
hey silent actually doesn't say much how
much of a talk about a great listener I
love the movie attendance well it's
different like then maybe what your
teddies yes my tab is a little offended
by that today
you couldn't yeah so wait I hear that
Tom Hanks gave you an interesting gift
at the end of the film
what cuz I am so excited about this
don't worry all of you have said the
same no that makes us worse I'm probably
gonna see stones they are I've been
working with a group of dimwits wait
tell them so he gets this kit they all
get this gift right a bunch of you got
the actors right yes a number and a
great number of the cast and crew got
this beautiful gift it's clearly
incredibly well-made it's made of
leather its inscribed
we're just not quite sure what it is or
maybe what to do with it I cannot wait
to ask my journal from mr. Hank titled
my autobiography
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this